this is Kinect Sports rivals connect
sports rivals is a collection of six
sports themed mini-games that range from
mildly enjoyable events like wake racing
and rock climbing to a thoroughly
underwhelming and absurd approximation
of soccer it's good for some short
bursts of goofy physical fun but Kinect
Sports rivals is neither a strong
assortment of motions and 12 games nor
an entirely promising showcase for the
capabilities of the new Kinect coach is
gonna tell you how to not totally
humiliate yourself out there before you
compete in your first event rivals
invites you to create your own champion
the digital representation of you who
will battle it out in sporting events
across the games island setting for this
process the Kinect scans your face then
creates a character who may or may not
bear a recognizable likeness to you the
shape of the face might have an uncanny
similarity to yours or you might see no
resemblance whatsoever between yourself
and your champion still it's always fun
to see what the game comes up with when
you do get to the island Kinect Sports
rivals starts by putting its best foot
forward you're ushered into your new
life as a sporting champion with some
wake racing what we might more commonly
call jet ski racing the controls are
simple intuitive and responsive to steer
you turn your arm like you're turning
handlebars and you can ease up on the
throttle by opening your right hand when
you go over ramps you can do flips with
a quick lean forwards or backwards and
you can lean from side to side to turn
more sharply the courses are gorgeous
and there's a sense of impact with the
water as your jetski crashes against
larger waves
rock climbing also works quite well here
you just move your arms and then close
your hands to grasp hand holds then move
your arms down to pull yourself up it's
especially fun when competing with a
friend because you can grab opponents by
the leg and send them plummeting to a
digital demise camera angles create a
sense of precariousness as you cling to
the undersides of rock surfaces it's too
simple to stay interesting for long but
it's hard to imagine the activity of
rock climbing being more effectively
converted into a Kinect activity than it
is here
bowling plays out exactly as you'd
expect you make a motion mimicking the
release of a bowling ball to make your
champion release his or her bowling ball
the motions you have to make to put spin
on the ball or exaggerate it so it
doesn't feel as natural as saying we
sports bowling but it's still satisfying
to wrap up the spares and strikes
similarly tennis is played by just
making swinging motions with your arm
and sending the ball rocketing past your
opponent faster than he or she can react
feels good
the last two events however are
exercises in absurdity and frustration
in target shooting you just point at the
screen moving your hand around to line
up crosshairs with targets once a target
is lined up you fire automatically some
targets need to be shot in sequence and
other targets have skulls on them
hitting these costs you points even if
this worked perfectly pointing at a
screen would hardly be a thrilling way
to spend your time but it doesn't work
perfectly crosshairs sometimes jitter
around which is a big problem in an
event that's supposed to be entirely
about precision rivals version of soccer
is a silly attempt to boil the sport
down to something that can be played
just by kicking and occasionally banging
your head you kick the ball from one
team member to another to another timing
and bending your kicks to avoid
defenseman who slide back and forth the
game doesn't respond to all of your
kicking motions and making shots on goal
can be infuriating when you clearly try
to kick the ball to one side or another
and then see it fly straight into the
middle of the goal and the goalkeepers
eat your hands
surrounding the events or progression
systems that have your champion earning
coins fans and experience points but if
the events aren't good enough to keep
you coming back these unnecessary
systems won't either Kinect Sports
rivals is an inconsistent collection
that'll get you up off the couch and
moving around for a bit of mild fun but
that's about the best you can say for it
yeah drink it baby
you